we have more big news out of Las Vegas
Kelly Clarkson got emotional talking to
us about Carrie Underwood's pregnancy
now Carrie who recently revealed she had
suffered multiple miscarriages of was
talking about it all in 80 on lines
lauren zima got Kelly just before she
hit the stage at the iHeartRadio Music
Festival
you know is today just being a die-hard
super great I mean I live I don't
usually get to go see concerts and
Carrie's killing it and she's pregnant
what so and I hated singing pregnant
[Music]
Carrie Underwood cover her baby bump
with a loose shimmery blouse fellow Idol
champ Kelly Clarkson praised Kari for
being so open and honest recently about
having suffered three miscarriages in
the last two years I was a millionaire
because I was like it's so important
that you talk about it I know it you
don't have to because it's a hard thing
to do but it makes women that feel and
fear or feel like something's wrong with
them it makes them feel comfortable and
that people go through it I'm gonna give
me cry before I perform wrong and she's
pregnant with that new baby how great is
it to see her out here donor oh that's
that's amazing I didn't this is news to
me that she's pregnant so I'm very very
happy for them
Kelly also shared details about her new
talk show set to air a year from now we
see the kids on it at all Oh probably
because we have four of them so I'm sure
we'll pop up every now and then we have
normal people somebody's music a lot of
heart it's cool it was fun to shoot the
pilot so yes look Brian just told us he
wants to be honest he better be on that
my friend would you go on Kelly's new
show certainly certainly she'll return
my calls
et was the only crew outside the I heart
stage where Mariah had a sweet hello and
so did Justin Timberlake he performed
with Shawn Mendes
[Music]
he's one of my all-time music idols and
people in general
[Music]
[Applause]